ON IN RELIEF OF THOMAS STARTS F
ZONE.
AT THE OTHER THE BLADE OF THE
STICK.
MORE TRAFFIC TO TH ROOKIE, THE .
LARKIN'S GOT IT.
SWITCHES TO THE FORE
AGAIN.
FIGHTING OFF A CHECK.
GOT IT BACK FOR OESTERLE.
TAKING NO CHANCES. WILL BREAK F.
PARISE.ZI.
THE WORK DOWN LOW ON MAYFIELD
WITHOUT A ST KEYSER AND DEFLECT
WIDE.SE -- WELL,
THOSE THIRTEEN GAMES THEY
STARTEDLAYS IT.
MOVED AHEAD BY LIDSTROM.NA.
HE WAS TOO WELL COVERED.
GRABBED THERE BY THEMSELVES OUT
SEASON BUT HAS BEENWINGS IN THE
CHANGE AND NAMESTNIKOV.
LIDSTROMING ABOUT HIM.
HE PLAYS EXTRAORDINARILY HARD.
FOR PELECH.
FORCED THERE BY LARKIN.F HE JUS
TIP OF THAT.
WE'LL SEE ON THIS ONE.
I DON'T KNOW.
INTO THE BENCH WENT
ROUGH SEASON. IT FOR RAYMOND.
FIRST TEN MINUTES OF THE PERIOD.
AND
LINDSTROM.
PRETTY GOOD
>> WAY BACK WHEN. RED WINGS HAVE
OFFENSIVE ENVELOPE
>> 27TH AND 29TH.
RIGHT  FRUSTRATION
RIGHT THERE.
>> UPSTAIRS WE GO TO KEN AND
TAKEN BY ERNIE THROUGH HIS LEGS.
NO ONE THERE IN RED TO PICK IT
SIX HURRICANES IN COVID
PROTOCOL. THIS
PLACE STARTED
SHOT BLOCKEDJKOVIC GOT A PIECE